hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at the chum
bucket now this is a sequel to five
nights at the Krusty Krabs but I
actually couldn't get that game to work
but this one was highly requested and is
highly rated - so supposedly it's a very
good five nights at Freddy's game hello
I thought I just got a call someone else
want to talk to the Marquis mu I'm here
to answer all your questions you must be
the old security guard yeah I've been
told so much about you from my superior
uh-huh
allow me to introduce myself for all
intensive purposes I am the
second-in-command here at the Chum
Bucket cool and my boss has put me in
charge at you lose you and your buddy on
the phone there have caused us quite a
lot of trouble by escaping that fire we
can't have anyone finding out what
happened to the old restaurant that's
where you come in no doubt your friend
out there is gonna come and find you so
we're keeping you alive until that
happens essentially you're gonna be
acting as bait don't get any hope from
that though you're still on our hit list
so unlike my superior I prefer a much
more indirect method of killing my prey
let me explain you're not alone in this
restaurant inside is a group of
animatronics just like your old job
uh-huh this time though their sole
function is to kill you yeah from the
hours of 12:00 until 6:00 in the morning
the generator can only supply two pieces
of equipment with power any one time
and that includes both doors the camera
and the flashlight on your desk
okay so be sure to use them
strategically that's all for tonight
okay
there's more to tell but it's not quite
relevant again I'll let you know when
the time comes anyway good luck I like
how your southern accent kind of see I'm
gonna need it I'm gonna need your accent
back because it slipped away as you
progressed reading scripts hello-o as
the time started well everything's
actually in 3d here I can see everything
moving around and there's four floors
how is that even remotely fair that's
probably not meant to be this is so
weird I don't know what happened in the
first game because obviously I wasn't
able to get to work and this one was a
hey are you doing Patrick II oh you're
looking so fine and fresh and dandy but
I mean hi Patrick how did you get there
so quickly alright so I actually have no
idea how hard this game is actually
gonna be oh and all my doors are open
and oddly off like I can see like
there's something behind me or something
I have no idea what's going on there so
oh wow hi spongebob
you've been working out the episode were
you and Patrick wrestled you know you
know the one you remember it was great
okay great I can't wait for you to get
with your friend and great okay great
we're sandy where's sandy
oh this is so much fun so it's basically
good night hi are you still there
[Music]
Patrick so funny free so well anyway to
summarize like I can only serve I can
only do two things at once and he looks
so angry oh come on
what is this piss on a die I'm gonna die
how is this fair
what happened
why'd that happen what happened to me
why did the Douro read how was I
supposed to win and what world was that
fair can they like move when I'm like
Sol Sol Sol Sol Sol Sol Sol Sol la Sol
what am i what am i what am i what am I
supposed to do about that okay
what do I do everybody tell me what I'm
supposed to do what am I supposed to do
I've no idea what I'm supposed to do by
the time you tell me it's gonna be far
too late but okay cool
all right great great great great
where's Patrick I bet that I was at the
sound of a moving away oh okay oh okay I
don't I don't I don't like these robots
these robots are creepy they're not
quite as menacing it's actually weird
it's like they're a little less menacing
that they move it was more creepy that
because I have fear of mannequins so I
hate when things that aren't supposed to
move or moving but like with five nights
at Freddy's is all like the thing for
static anyway but still I don't want
them to kill me I'm not saying I want
them to come in this room oh no please
no don't get me Oh that'd be so horrible
No okay I might be weirded out oh vent
vent vent vent vent what do I need to
worry about a vent
oh that's how Patrick got me oh he got
me so good so who is that please what is
all I word what's the overdrive mean I
don't know what that means
oh I can use more than one thing all
that soap
that's cool I'd like that except that I
don't so weird so many new things to
keep track of that's what I do like
about when it comes to the five minutes
of Freddie's loans because it's the same
basic concept but there are some new
elements too and that's what makes it
good market moves winner markiplier when
I won I won I practically won
I should probably celebrate now before
actually won because that's what ever I
heard that oh that oh oh not like it a
little bit of okay you really know okay
I get it okay so anyway that was that I
guess I'll keep going like why not I
didn't really get to the meat of the
matter so might as well come five nights
let's try night to see what oh hi thank
you thank you for that that was great
thank you yes please talk to me I guess
I take it for the lack of red mist
spattered on that window
that means you survived your first night
and I take it your accent still go on to
things I forgot was the relevance of the
air ducts throughout the facility yeah I
got it the animatronics well one of them
might try to get into your office
through them though don't worry we've
given you remote control over the
ventilation covers directly above your
office long queues access from inside
your security cameras I couldn't well
you'll figure it out fortunately for you
they don't even count towards your power
budget overdrive already that's linked
to the generator gents allow you to use
an extra piece of equipment be careful
though huh I still have to cool down
okay
it'll also scramble any animatronics
that are standing too close to it I
think there's one in particular that
might try and go down there to mess with
it keep an eye on that with you where's
the key where where where you watch
everyone else as well what
I don't think there's all that interest
because there's something don't worry
about all that there anyway I'll talk to
you again tomorrow night okay don't go
at the Frick up your Frank alright so
there's there's actual events throughout
the time for the party to start okay so
apparently their events all around the
facility that I need to go or I need to
keep an eye on that's why I need to look
around and apparently there's a
generator somewhere around here hey mr.
technical man whoa hi okay so he's gonna
try to get in my bed
but I don't know which one all right so
that was the thing cool he's still there
he's trying to get through easy man
Sarah like why there has to be four
floors why can't there just be not four
floors hi
is that another van that's another van
isn't that's another goddamn van
that's another goddamn van you were not
beaten what the hell was that all about
wait where was I god damn it's so
confusing hi tentacle man you're really
creepy I don't like you of all the ones
in here I really don't like you
balls balls balls balls what's the
bluffing okay okay perfect okay I'm okay
goddamn it why are there so many things
to keep track of it's such [ __ ] what
do we need to do something by the
generator some womb' over driven [ __ ]
was that someone there I thought someone
was there it looked like someone was
there okay hi okay alright then say what
about me I'll buffing your bummy uh okay
what was that what I see what's that
over there
I saw something damn it what am I saying
[Music]
oh okay no one's above me I can't open
the door without turning on the light oh
I'm so screwed look he's probably gone
right oh [ __ ] okay okay what am i doing
what am i doing he's gone yeah okay
we're fine everything's fine
everything's great everything's great
shut up shut up right now you go out
there shut up okay okay fine fine fine
fine fine
still fine fire everybody fine everybody
okay survive cancer you all right
[ __ ] okay another hour Jesus how they
can live in another hour so who was he
talking about buying the vien by the
generator who was he talking about that
that didn't make any sense what are you
talking about
I don't even know where the generator is
anybody above me all right okay all
right okay all right okay all right okay
all right I win I'm a winner who's that
who the fire you know I saw that those
are thing that was are you saying my dad
ding dong ding dong Bing bong
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man that was nuts all right cool
great all right cool all right cool
all right cool all right cool all right
cool okay I think that's enough blind
panic for one day that was five nights
at the chum bucket but I may not be done
if you guys want to see more of this
game let me know in the comments down
below I don't know if I'm gonna play it
to completion because I don't want to
play too many of these five nights at
Freddy's clone but this one is actually
really well made I can see why people
recommended it so if you want to see
more of it let me know and also if you
have other suggestions for more scary
games that I can play in the future let
me know in the comments as well thank
you everybody so much for watching check
out the other scary
[Music]